SICK AND YOU NEED HELP FROM THE
SAME GOVERNMENT YOU WILL REST
YOUR LIFE.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LEADERS ARE
PROMISING TO IMPROVE THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IN THE WAKE
OF THE UPROAR OVER THE USE OF
SUPERDELEGATES IN RECENT
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES.
CORRESPONDENT ELLISON BARBER
LOOKS OVER THE PARTY IS
CONSIDERING AND WHETHER IT WOULD
MAKE ANY REAL DIFFERENCE.
>> IN THE WORLD OF THE
SUPERDELEGATES.
>> SUPERDELEGATES HAVE BEEN USED
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY FOR
YEARS.
>> ELECTED OFFICIALS, THE UBER
ACTIVISTS TO BE GIVEN VOTING
RIGHTS AT THE CONVENTION.
>> OFFICIALS SAY SUPERDELEGATES
HAVE NEVER OVERTURNED THE WILL
OF THE OTHER DELEGATES BUT IN
2008 AND IN 2016 THEY BECAME A
BIG ISSUE.
TO SUM, PROOF OF A RIGGED
SYSTEM.
>> OVER 400 OF THE
SUPERDELEGATES INDICATED THEIR
SUPPORT FOR SECRETARY CLINTON
BEFORE ANYONE ELSE WAS IN THE
RACE.
>> PARTY OFFICIALS DISAGREED
WITH THAT BUT ACKNOWLEDGED
PERCEPTION MATTERS.
>> WE FELL SHORT IN MANY WAYS.
WE FELL SHORT IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYBODY FELT THAT
THE CANDIDATE THEY WERE
SUPPORTING GOT A FAIR SHAKE.
>> PARTY LEADERS CREATED A
UNIFORMITY MISSION.
>> AS LONG AS THERE IS THE
PERCEPTION OF AN UNFAIR PROCESS,
YOU HAVE AN UNFAIR PROCESS.
ANY STEPS THE DNC TAKES TO TURN
IT AROUND OUR GOOD STEPS.
>> DNC MEMBERS VOTED TO EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE FINDINGS.
>> ONLY THOSE UNPLEDGED
DELEGATES THAT HAVE BEEN CARVED
OUT WOULD HAVE A VOTE ON THE
FIRST BALLOT.
WE REDUCED THE WEIGHT OF ALL